der alex in fast 3000 metern höhe die
schweiz so viele gletscher dass man eine
ganze bahnstrecke daran vorbei leben
kann
und die beginnt in st moritz den
berühmten skiort in khartum glauben
von hier aus wird regelmäßige gletscher
express richtung heimat und nur ein paar
mal im jahr die nostalgie variante der
glacier-express gut 50 gäste machen sich
gemütliche den hubwagen aus den 1930 er
jahren für die kaum mehr als 140
kilometer die der reguläre glatte
express in nur acht stunden zurücklegt
nimmt durch der nostalgie zug zwei tage
zeigt die strecke führt durch 91 tunnel
und über 291 brücken auf schmalspur
schienen schlängelt sich der platzierten
express von sankt moritz am ersten tag
zunächst über die albula bahn als eine
von nur drei eisenbahnstrecken weltweit
darf sich mit dem titel unesco welterbe
schlucken
gezogen werden die nostra die waggons
von einer nostalgie blog christopher
ohne steuert seine koffer die lokomotive
aus den 30er jahren in gemächlichem
tempo durch kurven tunnel und über
viadukte
[Musik]
gegen mittag erreicht der glacier
express 3 tal hier wurde der mächtige
strom noch junge wirtin den
restaurantwagen mittagessen wird
beim anschließenden körper kommt es
darauf an dass trotz schaukelei keinen
tropfen danebengehen schweizer präzision
trifft im glacier express auf schweizer
eisenbahn tradition
die eidgenossen sind ein volk von
bahnfahrern hat sich weiter wir haben
den längsten eigene bank gründen
aber die zweite 50 bei die siedlung aus
ostbayern die gäste jeden fall genießen
und so trödelt der langsamste
expresszüge welt durch den nachmittag
übernachtet wird übrigens nicht im zug
sondern in betrieben und der zweite tag
der reise beginnt mit ordentlich dampf
und mit einem ganz anderen zug am
furkapass bei andermatt muss der glacier
express in tunnel nehmen die passagiere
aber erleben eisenbahnromantik pur mit
der mehr als 100 jahre alten vorgabe an
[Musik]
steil hinauf geht es bergab antrieb bis
zum hass auf über 2000 meter höhe wo
auch mitte juli noch schnee liegt in der
schweiz ist es ein stetes auf und ab
vom vor papas geht es steil wieder
hinunter ins tal
von dort aus sind nicht mehr viele
kilometer bis nach st der größte teil
der strecke ist geschafft doch ein
gipfel genug steht noch aus der aletsch
gletscher in örtchen fliesst heißt es
deshalb wieder umsteigen seilbahn das
schließlich auch eine wahl besucht beim
unesco weltnaturerbe der aletsch ist der
größte und längste gletscher behalten
[Musik]
unten im tal verschwindet die
glitzerwelt hinter wolken während der
glacier pullman express richtung
matterhorn fährt auch das wird sich
heute im dunst höhen schade aber keinen
grund für trübsal
wer gemütlich so
vom hektischen alltag man kann sich das
richtig erholen und mal runter kaum ein
die natur genießen
gemütlich gute sätze aufgelösten das
wieder machen
so geht die langsame reise doch schnell
zu ende einfahrt ins amt mit dem
langsamsten schnellzug der welt
ein anti stress programm auf schienen